If you purchased a desktop computer, a
laptop computer, a tablet, a mobile
phone, or practically any other
computing device, then you know that
there has to be some type of link
between the hardware that you've
purchased and the application that you
need to use. That link is the operating
system. This is software that's running
on that computing device that controls
all of the interaction between the
different hardware components of that
device. There needs to be some type of
software that's able to move information
from your storage drive into memory.
There needs to be some interactions with
the CPU. And then we'll need some type
of input and output from your keyboard
and your monitor. Your operating system
is also the platform used by your
application. If you're running an
executable in an operating system, that
application was specifically written to
run in that OS. And of course, our
modern computers have many different
ways for us humans to be able to
interact with that system itself. This
operating system allows us to put
information into the computer, have the
computer process that information, and
then provide us with an
output. In this course, you'll learn a
lot about Windows, MacOss, Linux, and
many other operating systems. But there
are some commonalities between all of
these different OSS. One is file
management. When you need to store a
file, remove a file or change what
happens to be on that storage device,
the operating system is responsible for
doing that. You also want to run
applications, but the applications
themselves have a great deal of
overhead. There's interaction with the
memory inside of that device. You need
some way to store files or have swap
file information so you can swap things
in and out of memory to the storage
device. We also need a way to get
information into and out of that
computing device. One way to get
information into a device is with
something like a keyboard and a mouse.
And we might get information out of that
computer through the use of a printer, a
display or to have information stored on
a separate drive. And because we have
this operating system, we also need to
manage this operating system. So the OS
also includes its own set of utilities
that keeps that system running at peak
efficiency. One of the most popular
operating systems in the world is
Microsoft Windows. It has a significant
market presence and is used in
practically every organization in the
world. There are many different versions
of Microsoft Windows. You might find
Windows 10, Windows 11, Windows Server,
and certainly there will be newer
Windows versions as time goes on. This
popularity of Windows provides it with
the advantage of very large industry
support. If you need to find an
additional piece of hardware, install
new software, or find support for your
system, there are probably plenty of
folks that can help you with your
Windows issues. You also have a large
number of operating system options.
Although we're talking about Microsoft
Windows, as it's a single OS, there are
actually many different Windows
operating systems for many different
purposes. So, if you're using a laptop
at home or you're using a server in a
large data center, there's a Windows
version that's right for you. And
because Windows is so popular, there are
many developers writing their software
to run in this operating system. So if
you need any type of business software,
entertainment software, or utility,
there's probably a version available for
Microsoft Windows. As security
professionals have found, this
popularity also brings some downsides.
This makes a very big target for anyone
who's trying to gain access to data that
might be stored inside of a Windows OS.
So there's a very large group of
attackers that are working on software
to gain access to your Windows system,
but there's also a very large group of
cyber security professionals that are
dedicated to protecting this operating
system. You also have the challenge of
Microsoft Windows supporting many
different types of hardware. It is the
responsibility of the hardware
manufacturer to write driver software
that will work properly with this
operating system. Some manufacturers
have very good drivers, some
manufacturers don't. So, this might give
you some challenges when you're trying
to integrate new hardware into your
system and challenges to be able to
support this hardware over the long
term. This is the Windows 11 operating
system and there are consistencies that
you will begin to see across these
different OSS. For example, on this
desktop, you can see there are number of
applications available. We have a bar at
the bottom that shows us available
applications that we can quickly start.
There's also status information on the
screen and there is a recycle bin and of
course we could add other icons to this
desktop as well. Linux is an operating
system that is absolutely free. This is
open-source software that is created and
maintained by thousands of individuals
all over the world. When you install
Windows 11, you're installing an
operating system that is exactly the
same as any other Windows 11 you would
install. But with Linux, there are
different distributions of Linux.
Sometimes these distributions are
focused on performing a set of very
specific tasks and sometimes these
distributions are designed for general
use. Generally, you would install the
Linux distribution that fit best with
your needs. One of the significant
advantages of Linux is there's no cost
to use it. There's no cost to purchase
the operating system. There's no ongoing
maintenance, no monthly fees that you
would have to pay. Linux also works on
almost any hardware you might find and
there is a very large user community
that can help with supporting this
software. Since we're relying on
knowledgeable individuals to help
maintain this operating system, you may
find that newer hardware or newer
laptops may not be 100% compatible with
the Linux distribution that you're
using. And it may be a challenge to find
the right driver to be able to use this
new hardware. And although there are
many places online to get support for
your Linux software, there's no one
Linux company you would go to to provide
any type of technical support. You would
need to use this community of
individuals to help support the Linux
distribution that you're using. Here's a
screenshot from a Linux desktop and you
can see there are a number of
similarities to the Windows desktop that
we were seeing. There are large number
of icons on the front screen. We have a
taskbar here, but it's on the left side
instead of being on the bottom. You
could, of course, move this to the
bottom if you would like. And there are
a number of search bars and buttons on
the screen that are very similar to what
you would find in Windows or other
operating
systems. And one of the other large
operating systems that you will
undoubtedly run into in your
administrative tasks is Apple's Mac OS.
Mac OS is a desktop that runs on Apple
hardware exclusively. It's not one that
you can simply install on any machine
that you might find. One of the things
that Mac OS is very well known for is
its ease of use. And certainly Mac OS is
well known for its user interface and
overall usability. The hardware that Mac
OS runs on is hardware that is available
exclusively from Apple. And since Apple
manufactures the hardware and then
writes the operating system for that
same hardware, the entire system is very
compatible. Mac OS is also designed for
security in mind and you may find fewer
security concerns with Mac OS as
compared to something like Linux or
Windows. But these advantages can also
be disadvantages. If you can if you can
only run Mac OS on Apple hardware, then
you'll need to purchase that hardware
from Apple. You're not able to run Mac
OS on other non-Apple hardware devices.
There are also fewer people using Mac OS
than using something like Windows. So,
we tend to see more industry support for
Windows than we do Mac OS simply because
of the number of people using those
operating systems. And since Mac OS runs
exclusively on Apple hardware, it tends
to have a higher initial hardware
cost. Here's a screenshot from the
desktop of Mac OS. And as you can tell,
it is very similar to a Windows or a
Linux desktop. We have a workspace on
the desktop itself. There's a bar at the
bottom where we can start different
applications. and you can see icons and
buttons on the screen that are very
similar to those other operating
systems. Another OS that has taken a bit
of a departure from the traditional
operating system is Chrome OS. Chrome OS
was created by Google and although it's
based on the Linux kernel, it does have
a different look and feel than using a
traditional Linux operating system. The
objective of Chrome OS was to have most
of the operating system revolve around
the browser itself. In this case, the
browser is the one made by Google, which
is Chrome. And that, of course, is why
this is the Chrome OS. Most of the
applications that you will use in Chrome
OS are inside of that browser. Chrome OS
was designed to be a relatively
straightforward operating system with a
minimum amount of overhead. There are
many different manufacturers making
hardware for Chrome OS, and many of
these are laptopbased systems. Because
most of these applications are running
in a browser, there is a significant
network connectivity requirement. You
need to have connection to the cloud to
be able to run these cloud-based
applications. And if you don't have
connectivity, you're not able to use
those apps. iPad OS includes a desktop
browser, specifically Safari, which is a
different version than what you might
find on an iPhone. You also support a
second monitor through the use of a
function known as Sidecar. There's also
keyboard support, multitasking, and much
more that supports the hardware that
iPad OS is based on. Although it looks
very similar, the operating system that
runs on Apple's iPhones are actually a
different operating system known as
Apple iOS. Unlike Linux, which is an
open-source operating system, all of the
Apple operating systems are closed
source. You do not have access to the
source code of iOS. And iOS is an
operating system that will only run on
Apple hardware. If you want to develop
applications for iPad OS, iOS, or even
Mac OS, then you'll need to use Apple's
software developers kit that runs on the
Mac OS operating system. Before these
applications you write are available in
the Apple App Store, they need to be
tested and approved by Apple directly.
Once Apple approves them, they're
available in the App Store where anyone
can purchase and download to use on
their iOS or iPad OS
devices. Of course, the other large
manufacturer of software for mobile
devices is Google through the use of
Google Android. Google Android is
maintained by a consortium of companies
known as the Open Handset Alliance. And
Android itself is an open-source
operating system that's based on Linux.
Unlike iOS or iPad OS which only runs on
Apple hardware, Google Android is
supported by many different
manufacturers and there are many
different types of hardware available
that can use Google Android. You can
develop apps for Google Android using
Windows, Mac OS and Linux using Android
software developers kit. You can also
make those apps available from the
Google Play Store and a number of
thirdparty sites as well.
These different manufacturers of
operating systems have different
deployment and support requirements. For
example, end of life is something we
should always be aware of when using an
operating system and different companies
will set different standards for end of
life. For example, the end of life
requirements for Apple products will be
very different than those created for
Microsoft products. One thing that is
very similar across all of these
different operating systems is the
requirement to keep these OSS updated
with the latest version of software.
This not only ensures the operating
system will run at peak efficiency, it
also ensures that security patches are
always updated in the OS. But just
because these different operating
systems run on different hardware and
the operating systems are written by
different organizations doesn't
necessarily mean there isn't some type
of compatibility. For example, you can
create documents, spreadsheets, media,
and other types of data and use those
also in other operating systems. But one
thing you cannot do in these operating
systems is take the executable from
Windows and try to run that executable
in Linux. If you're running an
application, that application has to be
written for the operating system that
you're using. Fortunately, many software
developers will create a standard file
format that they can move between
different operating systems without any
type of problem. And you may find that
many applications have become web-based,
which means you can effectively run them
in any browser regardless of the
operating system.